so in 2015 we this conversation or ask
you what you're afraid of the big worry
for me I would say even a likelihood
during my lifetime is a big epidemic so
let me ask you the reverse again I'm
thinking three or five years into the
future beyond just a vaccine what are
you hopeful for what do you hope for
well I hope this draws the world
together
I mean after World War two we
successfully avoided having another
world war you know it's a phenomenal
thing we haven't you know blown off a
nuclear weapon as' as part of a conflict
we did that by binding ourselves
together through a variety of
institutions including w john howard til
Roosevelt and Stalin dedicated their
Nations to the foundations for permanent
peace through a United Nations
Organization here
this is a tragic event whatever good
comes out of this will in no way make up
for the problems that it causes the
disease got into exponential growth in a
lot of Europe in the United States and
so the toll there is greater than I
would have expected we're learning about
how to do testing well a lot of
countries got that right and did it very
early on I think part of it is that the
minor epidemics we had really didn't hit
the US so if you look at the Asian
countries that did well places like
Taiwan or South Korea because they were
hit with MERS or SARS they had the
PlayBook they opened the PlayBook and
they went through those steps and any of
them wrote down you know step one
identify all PCR machine step to get
supplies for PCR machines we haven't
done that in a reasonable way today we
don't really know what's gonna happen in
developing countries where most of the
world population lives but unless
there's some magical factor the
likelihood that the vast majority of the
deaths will be there it's harder for
them to socially isolate you know they
need to get food there isn't this
ability to do what we've done job people
are suffering there is no evil it should
say to us okay this science is important
let's use it to avoid pandemics and for
other things
the US Congress that allocates resources
has been the most generous on HIV
funding for the entire world you know it
started under a Republican ministration
and to me too severe and urgent crisis
abroad tonight I proposed the Emergency
Plan for AIDS relief the US government
has helped the health of the entire
world been a huge part of the reduction
in death and so I do think what you're
seeing in this short term in terms of
how the u.s. is engaging halt funding of
the World Health Organization while a
review is conducted it's not where we'll
end up
I don't see a change in the US Congress
and saying hey in this case not only is
a humanitarian
it's about strategic relationships and
it's about making sure the disease isn't
coming back in to the US as we
participate in global commerce that we
benefit immensely from everybody brings
to the epidemic their hopes that maybe
they had before and I've always believed
in global cooperation that human ability
to take a much worse situation and craft
it into the institutions that and the
economic growth and innovation that
we've had between World War two and now
I hope that this looks like that
[Music]